we are very excited about our next guest
I've been babbling and gushing to them
all morning because I love this movie
his name is Luke Bracey stars in the new
romantic comedy one true love s like
loves Bracey plays Jesse who's married
to his high school sweetheart her name
is Emma until he disappears following a
helicopter crash years later now Emma's
engaged to someone else when Jesse is
discovered alive forcing Emma to make a
very difficult decision now in this clip
Jesse and Emma are trying to reconnect
after he returns home here's a look
I'm just glad that neither of us are
stuck anymore and we can start living
again for travel traveling you don't
want to settle somewhere safe oh yeah
home base sure
now I was thinking Venice Beach anywhere
in California would be good I mean
what's the best time of our lives
Mexican food was top-notch and you can
work from anywhere right and travel
riding can be wherever we want well I
don't um
I haven't written on travel piece in
years
really
yeah store but I just assume you're
still
what you wanted to do
Luke Bracey joins us listen Luke I think
I don't think that clip does this movie
Justice I have to set it up because
they're married uh that your characters
are married but he's in this helicopter
crash he's gone for four years and they
had a very good marriage very solid gone
for four years and at her engagement
party you get a phone call she gets a
phone call and he's back you're back
you're alive what's a girl to do
I mean I'm certainly glad I wasn't
putting uh Emma's position in that um
but also equally for my character coming
home and finding out your wife has a
fiance is a bit of a shock to the system
yeah but you said you didn't want Jesse
to be the hurt character her in this
movie because it was interesting I kept
going back and forth honestly as I was
watching it made me very wobbly because
I said well of course that's her husband
she has to be with him and then simu Lou
Who plays the person she's engaged to
they also have a very good relationship
too but you said you didn't want his
character defined by hurt but it is hurt
yeah he is hurt and you know I think one
of his things coming back from you know
years on a kind of desert island I think
the last thing you want to do is is kind
of wallow in that I think for his
character he wants to get his life back
you know he's got this opportunity at a
second chance at life and be able to
kind of have fun and laugh and and I
think that's what kept Him alive in
those years away by himself is that the
idea that he could come back and and and
get his enjoyable fun life back with the
with the love of his life so yeah having
like hurt be the center of it I think as
a character he wants to move on from
that and and every great rom-com has a
deep philosophical question at the
center I mean that seriously and this
one is
can you have two soul mates can you have
two one true love at the same time at
the same time at the same time I think I
think that's what this movie explores
and the idea that love and and the
people that you love are people that you
grow with right and that you are able to
evolve with and become you know the
people that you are by by spending your
time with them and and there's people
that you can have great connections with
and great moments with and become great
people with and and then there's people
that you can grow into and you can you
can you can learn to love and if things
have gone differently look you would
have been a rugby player not an actor
huh yes that would have been it but I
thought you were going to say I used to
model because I when you walked in I
went wow wow he's a handsome guy yeah
thank you very much gal I'll give you
that fifty dollars later yeah but you
you like rugby too yeah that was my that
was my passion as a kid yeah I really
really loved it um but I'll tell you
what uh pretending to be a tough guy is
a bit easier than actually you still
love acting you still love this job I
love it it's great fun I've been so
blessed with able to do this job and to
kind of fall into it and to make a bunch
of different films in a bunch of
different places meet different people
and lovely people like yourself to meet
us today that's true
American accent I didn't know that you
were Australia what's the key to nailing
an American accent I don't know it's a
bit of you know we're kind of
we get a lot of American culture and
stuff growing up in Australia a lot of
movies and TV shows and stuff like that
so in a way it kind of is subtly there
but one thing I always try and do you
just turn it on right now I try and
focus on my R's oh okay my tongue really
low down in the back of my mouth
[Laughter]
advice you can give to someone after
completing after this movie there's lots
of advice in this movie that's a really
tough one
um stay away from helicopters stay away
from helicopters and uh and grow with
people yeah there we go Luke Bracey
congratulations cheering you on this is
not your first rodeo continue to soar
you can see one true loves in theater
starting April 7th and will be available
to rent or buy on digital April 14th but
always better see a movie on the big
screen we'll be right back